Good morning, John.
I'm gonna be completely honest.
Sometimes I feel like a huge, gigantic failure. (Good start, pal.)
And we all feel like that and we're all petrified of failure. (Not me, buddy.)
But John, one thing that gets me through all of my failures
and keeps me trying new projects, day in and day out,
despite the fact that I probably will fail
is knowing that there are other people who have made decisions
that led to much bigger, much, much more significant failures (Like me.)
than I will ever even have the opportunity
to even get close to matching the level of those failures.
Today, so that you and the rest of the world can know that your failures,
no matter how big they seem to you, are actually insignificant,
I am going to give you a list of the
Top 7 most epic fails of history
that aren't in any specific order and that are actually
just the ones that I think are the most interesting.
Let's start out in 1962, when a young four-man band walked in to Decca Studios for an audition.
The Decca Studios manager concluded that the band had quote, "No future in show business."
A mere two years later, that band that we all know as the Beatles, sold 50 million dollars of records.
Gigantic epic fail number 2 went a little bit like this.
"Men, congratulations. We have been fighting a war with the Greeks for many, many years.
They have all left, and behind, all that there is is this beautiful horse
that they have made us to congratulate us for our victory over them.
Let us bring it into the walls of our city and leave it unguarded overnight."
Aaaaaaaah.
Epic fail number 3. Getting involved in a land war in Asia.
It's one of the classic blunders.
More specifically, if you're trying to take over all of Europe,
just don't, just leave Moscow out of it. Just let them be.
Similarly, if you are a small, though very technologically sophisticated
and interesting island nation, don't send a bunch of bombers over to, um,
bomb a country that you are not currently at war with.
Especially if that country has just developed the bomb that can destroy entire cities.
Sometimes it seems like these epic fails aren't being made by one person but they are,
they're decisions being made by men.
But on a more understandable scale, we have the 1960 performance of Wim Esajas.
The first Olympian from the nation of Suriname,
and his performance which will go down in history as the first Olympian from Suriname,
was to sleep through his race.
Moving further back in time, in 1876,
Western Union owned the entire system of communication in America.
In 1876, Gardener Green Hubbard approached Western Union with a patent for a device called the telephone.
The CEO of Western Union went ahead and bypassed the agent of sale,
wrote a letter directly to Alexander Graham Bell saying that
Western Union had no need of this "electrical toy."
Alexander Graham Bell, instead of closing up shop,
created his own telecommunications network which he named
American Telephone and Telegraph (AT&T).
The telephone became the most valuable patent in history.
So tell me in the comments, despite the fact that none of your failures
have ever led to the deaths of millions of people or to the loss of billions of dollars,
why are we so afraid of failure? (Because I am one.)
And in lieu of that, what is it do you think that you're afraid of? (MYSELF, OKAY?!)
John, I’ll see you on Monday. (Stay away from me.)